prêts pourront débattre nous sommes avec
un jean paul hamon médecin généraliste
président de la fédération des médecins
de france bonsoir jean pierre merci
d'être avec nous à ses côtés bertrand
legrand médecin généraliste lui aussi à
tourcoing bonsoir bertrand le grand
merci d'être avec nous on vient d'en
parler longuement l'inde la chine
on va parler de la nouvelle zélande
évidemment après est-ce que c'était
prévisible cette résurgence en tout cas
à pékin parce que là on peut vraiment
parler de résurgence pour ce qui est de
la chine et comment on l'expliquait à
vous l'honneur jean paul a écouté il n'y
a aucune raison qui ait pas de nouveaux
cas en chine on en a on en a chez nous
l'épidémie n'est pas terminée le virus
circule toujours
et ça n'est pas et ça n'est pas une
surprise l'ennui c'est que là ça arrive
à pékin pour les chinois et que c'est
pas demain la veille que les des
relations internationales les vols
internationaux vont repartir sereinement
il est clair que le virus le virus
circule il faut respecter les mesures
barrières et puis maintenant on est
enfin armé comme on n'était pas au début
c'est à dire que on a les protections
pour les soignants on a des masques pour
les ports les français on a on a des
tests et puis et puis on a quand même un
dispositif qui est très simple basé sur
le médecin traitant en relation avec la
caisse d'assurance maladie qui permet
d'identifier le patient est de dépister
les les cas contactez de confiner les
gens donc vraiment pas ce que vous
débordez ce sont les bains on va parler
justement tout à l'heure de ce qu'à
foncer mais pour bien comprendre
justement parce que c'est ce qui nous
inquiète quand on voit la chine déjà
mesuré un petit peu l'important c'est ce
qu'on parle de résurgence voilà il
faudrait pas qu'on raconte n'importe
quoi beaucoup de médias le font déjà
avant nous pardonnez moi voilà mes chers
confrères mais bon une centaine de cas à
pékin
dr legrand c'est beaucoup c'est pas
beaucoup c'est normal c'était prévisible
c'est très difficile de savoir si c'est
beaucoup pas beaucoup puisque par
définition au démarrage il semblerait
que la chine ait minimisé le nombre de
cas qu'elle avait et donc on ne sait pas
si c'est une résurgence où elle avait
minimisé des cas avant et maintenant
elle nous dirait la vérité ou est ce
qu'elle nous disait pas la vérité avant
elle nous dit toujours pas la vérité
maintenant c'est quelque chose qui est
forcément inquiétant puisque les données
chinoises ne sont pas transparentes
alors ce qu'on note quand même c'est que
les carrés sont résurgent dans la
capitale qui est pékin ce qui est très
mauvais au niveau politique en chine et
donc du coup pour en arriver à fermer
des quartiers de pékin
on peut se douter que là que la
résurgence et sûrement beaucoup plus
importante que ce qu'on le pense on en
revient donc à la france jean paul
huchon est ce que ça préfigure ce qui
pourrait se passer dans notre pays
puisque évidemment désormais écouter non
je pense qu'en france on n'a pas fini on
a on doit avoir 1000 ou 2000 cas encore
chaque jour donc clairement l'épidémie
n'est pas terminée on peut pas parler de
deuxième vague puisque la première vague
à la java était terminée c'est les
français sont enfin des confiné ce qui
est une bonne chose
maintenant si on apprend à vivre avec ce
virus est à portée des vases qui a
respecté les mesures barrières même
yahia l'utilisation de 2,7 de cette
application qui et qui est critiquée de
ce top cow fitr qui qui permettrait à
mon avis mois de rouvrir les salles de
spectacle les stades en toute sécurité à
condition que que les français le
télécharge parce que là pour le moment
c'est pas avec un million cinq coups de
millions de téléchargements
d'applications qu'on va qu'on va régler
le problème alors on tout le monde crie
au flicage
des données etc mais mais c'est une
explication qu'on charge volontairement
et qu'on peut décharger alors maintenant
il paraît que le gouvernement a ouvert
la porte au stockage de ces données je
me demande bien ce qui pourrait en faire
docteur legrand déjà sur ce diagnostic
un de votre confrère il n'y a pas de
deuxième vague car tout simplement la
première n'est pas terminée est ce que
vous êtes aussi sévère parce que les
chiffres qu'on publie ou qu'on publie
plus d'ailleurs nous on tient les
publiés montrent tous les jours qu'il ya
vraiment une
une baisse d admission en hôpitaux et
des réanimations est-ce que voilà c'est
une chimère l'épidémie est toujours bel
et bien là
selon-vous dr legrand je pense qu'on a
des exemples par exemple nous dans le
nord on a un superbe cluster sur le chru
de lille alors quand c'est à l'hôpital
qui est le cluster ça devient vraiment
inquiétant après en nombre de malades
qui sont admis à l'hôpital
non c'est pas inquiétant ça semble être
avoir fortement diminué mais
rappelez-vous que l'on a toujours du
retard par rapport au virus quand on
l'analyse puisque on analyse toujours
avec quatorze jours de retard en arrière
avec les hospitalisations c'est au moins
20 à 30 jours de retard donc là on est
simplement en train d'analyser la fin du
confinement le début d'idée confinement
c'est tout ce qu'on fait donc il va
falloir du temps avant que le virus
remonte avec une certaine inertie ce qui
est sûr c'est que on avait sept cent
mille tests à réaliser par semaine on
les fait pas et donc comme on ne les
fait pas soit disant parce qu'ils
appliquent une malade mais je vous
rappelle qu'un test de dépistage c'est
bien pour trouver des malades et non pas
pour trouver pour tester un maximum de
tests positifs et donc comme on ne fait
pas ces tests
on laisse filer partir 2 3 4 5 10
malades et c'est de là que repartent une
épidémie je vous rappelle que l'épidémie
mondiale quand même partie de 1 ou 2 cas
et non pas de des centaines de milliers
de cas jean pas les mandats corps avec
ce diagnostic on a des tests mais on ne
teste pas non mais je suis d'accord avec
je suis d'accord il faudrait tester qui
et comment ça veut dire que vous et moi
voilà on se sent pas malin il fallait
quand même se faire tester de manière
systématique c'est vrai que c'est un
petit peu compliqué comment on devrait
mettre cela en place
là maintenant on connaît enfin
l'épidémie amazing baby baby baby vous
dire comment je fais dans mon cabinet
puisque je teste depuis le 4 mai et deux
hôtesses de manière aléatoire c'est à
dire que toute personne qui veut faire
un test je lui fais un test au démarrage
j'ai trouvé jusqu'à 10% de tests
positifs sur les huit le store qui sont
actuellement dans le nord 3 contiennent
mes patients dans les tous premiers
voilà je pense que le dépistage
aléatoire c'est ce qui est logique de
faire statistiquement parlant et donc on
doit le faire alors après il ya une
deuxième point qui est très essentiel
c'est que si on prescrit un test en
espérant que le patient haye le faire au
laboratoire on va subir une perte qui
est très importante et donc il faut que
les médecins généralistes test chez eux
dans leur cabinet c'est vraiment pas
compliqué à faire maintenant qu'on a des
bons découvrions ça va beaucoup mieux et
donc du coup il faut le faire mais il
faut aussi être rémunérés pour le faire
et c'est clairement un problème aussi de
rémunération de l'acte et n'ont pas de
forfait qu'il nous faut avoir pour
motiver l'ensemble des médecins
généralistes car je vous rappelle qu'on
nous doit nous faire c'est accepter de
faire peut-être 100 ou 1000 tests pour
n'avoir qu'un seul positif c'est comme
ça qu'on est en une épidémie alors sur
l'éventualité justement d'une deuxième
vague
c'est ce qui nous anime ce soir on va
écouter ce qu'on dira le professeur
didier rahout une chose à surveiller de
très près ces nouvelle zélande
parce que la nouvelle zélande ne soit
dans l'hémisphère sud là des conditions
climatiques qui sont assez proches de
celles de la france dans l'hémisphère
sud est aussi une épidémie en nouvelle
zélande
cet été on peut redouter qui est même
timide épidémie l'hiver prochain en
france parce que c'est comme ça que ça
se passe pour la plupart de l'affection
aspirateur japonais dr house qui a
toujours ses analyses bien n'est pas
vous êtes d'accord vous ça me semble
assez logique parce qu'il dit il à il
n'a pas tort il n'a pas tort gg j'ai
toujours apprécié l'analyse de l'un
d'eux la fin d'épidémie
ou du mois la baisse il avait il l'avait
annoncé
hélas pour la nouvelle zélande il n'a
pas tort non plus c'est vrai qu'on n'est
pas à l'abri d'un redémarrage en en
octobre j'espère qu'on aura la paix au
moins jusqu'en octobre
sauf que là cette fois ci on sera on
sera quand même mieux armés et mais on
n'aura toujours pas de vaccin parce que
quoique annoncé laboratoires
pharmaceutiques ça va être vrai qu'on
n'aime pas que ça avant bertrand legrand
vous a souvent entendu ici même déploré
voilà qu'on avait pas de thèse padma ce
n'est qu'on allait certainement être
prêt pour la prochaine fois vous
justement vous souscrivez aussi à ce
diagnostic du docteur house il faut
surveiller la nouvelle zélande et voilà
1,6 à 1,5 grave cet été c'est mauvais
signe pour nous en octobre la chine
avait deux mois d'avancé sur nous vous
calculez la résurgence vous rajouter
deux mois juillet août par felipe
septembre on a on prend date
oui si jamais il devait y avoir une
saisonnalité effectivement mais encore
une fois on n'a pas éteint l'épidémie en
france et on se donne pas les moyens de
l'éteindre parce que tout simplement les
patients et la population n'a pas envie
d'en parler on a tous envie de tourner
la page une bonne fois pour toutes mais
est-ce que c'est raisonnable
la réponse c'est non en étant une
épidémie dans ce niveau l'an les
derniers cas si on laisse filer les
derniers cas ça reviendra d'une manière
ou d'une autre
aujourd'hui quels sont les dangers les
plus importants on parle de clusters ici
ou là qu'est ce qu'il faut à tout prix
éviter selon vous jean paul eymond il
faut il faut appliquer ce qu'on aurait
dû appliquer dès le début c'est à dire
que dès qu'on a un cas dès qu'on a un
cas positif on identifie sait c'est
qu'un contact on isole ces personnes là
on les teste et puis on les confine
jusqu'à ce qu'on soit certain qu'ils
aient pas développer la maladie
donc là dessus si on applique ça et
maintenant que les généralistes
l'ensemble des généralistes sont
impliqués
et que on peut et on a les moyens de
tester les gens je pense qu'on a les
moyens de contenir de contenir une
épidémie qui redémarre et oui il ya
également les déplacements estivaux qui
sont d'actualité puisque les frontières
ouvre celle de schengen a également
c'est quelque chose que vous craignez
bertrand legrand non les déplacements à
l'intérieur de la france
on n'a pas les interdire souhaite à
l'extérieur avant les frontières de la
france et de schengen bat à l'extérieur
de la france
si on n'a pas assez de cas en france un
peu toujours en importer un peu plus ce
sera rigolo à la sortie no sérieusement
il ya un moment donné ou faut quand même
être raisonnable je pense que les les si
on renvoie nos acheteurs en chine ils
vont revenir avec le virus ça fait comme
ça s'est passé comme ça la première fois
donc on reste et on qu'on va quand même
pas faire ça j'espère que là on est en
train de dénombrer le nombre de
personnes que l'on a en chine et
notamment résidant à pékin et qui sont
pas en train de revenir en camion en bus
et en avion parce que c'est quand même
ce qui fait passer la première fois
donc voila mon espère tous que la grèce
va être super sage et que pour une fois
elle va vraiment contacter les personnes
qui reviennent
merci on a tâché de suivre vos conseils
jean paul eymond si vous vouliez
rajouter quelque chose
non il n'a pas fait pas raison il a
parfaitement raison moi je suis vraiment
extrêmement inquiet d'aider des vols
internationaux qui ont repris et des
gens qui vont débarquer sans contrôle et
c'est certainement pas en prenant la
température par mon a fait au début qui
va régler quoi que ce soit quoi les gens
et il arrive on les confie dans l'est on
les teste et on les libère une fois
qu'ils condé certains guides au pôle
virus
non je suis vraiment très inquiet de la
reprise des vols internationaux sans
contrôle merci à tous les deux jean paul
hamon et bertrand legrand d'avoir été
avec nous